are your dms pretty flooded nowadays
like when it comes to just random dudes
just like you know doing the thing that
we perceive females to be the only
people that do but guys are bigger
creeps i feel like
like do you ever get the random dick pic
in the dna
like damn strangers dicks are just
flying at me like that one dude on
instagram they do it on snapchat they
got it real in facebook too but facebook
they gotta realize senior citizens are
sending you dick pics on facebook like
different people
what's going on
imagine hitting on somebody on facebook
where it's your government name and all
your friends and family are on there
what there's nothing discreet about that
i get the snapchat you just make up a
little [ __ ] username and you start
sending dick pics flying
i'm hoping somebody hits back you know
i've ever been to a public place and
someone's just sent you an unsolicited
airdrop photo nah like i was in line at
[ __ ] disneyland
and this [ __ ] just kept sending
me [ __ ] pictures of dicks
[Laughter]
it was like a variation of dicks and i
had to i and i just i just switched from
android to iphone so i don't know how to
turn this [ __ ] off
it's like somebody clearly in line doing
this to everybody you know
i'm just a dick pic dick pic oh there's
a brown one there's a white one there's
a pink one
[Music]
it was a good prank if i was if i was
like 14 with an iphone backing that i
would have been doing all kinds of wild
[ __ ] like
we used to egg people
hurry up you'd be driving down the road
people would be walking down the street
you throwing egg at them
yeah you're a bad girl on that one we
ate prostitutes once in a pimp almost
killed us when i was like 14. you do it
there's a street in phoenix arizona
called van buren it was the track where
all the [ __ ] would walk when they
were selling their vagina before only
fans before backpage even
shout out to backpage what happened to
y'all anyway
um
i think we're both high but yeah so this
is the street where all the hookers
would be [ __ ] back and forth back and
forth back and forth
this is like you know when uh
prostitutes who walked the street were
actually attractive not you know
crackheads yeah um but we used to on
like back then the prostitutes
yeah i mean when they were walking the
street nowadays if a chick is walking
the street [ __ ] you don't got internet
what are you doing
why are you out here
go in the [ __ ] hotel put an ad a
[ __ ] and relax jesus
[Laughter]
anyway
so we used to
fill up uh water balloons and buy
cartons of eggs and we had hit we'd toss
eggs at prostitutes
and then a pimp chased us once
but we used to just toss a like hit hit
prostitutes he was in the car and he got
in the car and chased down no no he like
like uh he pulled off and like was like
a [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] escalade
chasing us for like six lights
that was pretty crazy where i was 14 and
my best friend was like 15 we stole our
parents car and we just would go [ __ ]
do all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ]